we are here with the one and the only
billy porter
okay billy the last time you were here
you sang to a flower i sang to a flower
okay you called your people called and
said
drew has this idea she wants you to sing
to a flower i was like why not
okay yes
so see a thang to a flower what's so
crazy is okay i just want you to know
that i keep this in my bedside table
i see this every single night
when i open my bedside table drawer
because ironically billy
in my mind it was sort of like sesame
street right it was you and a flower
yeah like this yes and maybe acapella
something
beautiful and moody and simplistic and
pared down
yeah
and i walked on the set and i was like
oh my god
oh my god it's like
disco it's nighttime okay
whoa that was a pivot
i'm from the theater darling
[Applause]
i was like is billy going to be okay
with this is he going to like this i saw
it really differently is he going to be
here he's fine daddy's fine i saw it i
was like come on once it grow yes come
on let's do it
okay
all i want to do is honor you and make
you comfortable cut to
it's sunday morning about a week or two
later
and my phone is blowing up and my phone
doesn't blow up on a sunday morning like
i'm uber boring like that there's no
blow up of my phone ever
and i pick it so i'm like what's going
on is everything okay and they're like
um you were on saturday night live last
night
and they did this sketch about the drew
barrymore show and they spoofed me
what's bad about that
there's chloe feynman as me yes there's
keenan thompson as well as me
dressed like that and pumps on singing
to a flower i said i made it
[Applause]
daddy's
[Applause]
all the other friends of mine start
waking up jimmy fallon
gail king literally going dude you guys
have made it right
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you please get off the floor i mean
i'm not kidding though i want to tell
you something
after that
our show i have to get on the floor
six feet away
our show
shifted and people
understood from saturday night live that
they could enjoy themselves
and that we could take off with our
wings and have fun because we were in a
pandemic and nobody knew that
and i thank you for going on that
journey with me
[Applause]
okay
the show took flight after that that's
so sweet to know i didn't know that
attributed to you and i going for it and
then go
home i just want to give you all the
flowers in the world
right here good sweet thank you those
flowers are for you i'm gonna take them
and since you sang to a flower i feel
like i should return the favor oh shoot
what is happening
[Music]
[Applause]
i got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
in this world
[Music]
you